I mean I'm someone who's been private
about my personal life but like when it
happens in a big way I would want the
world know now that Priyanka Chopra and
Nick Jonas made their love official the
world is obsessed with the couple
serving up relationship goals on social
media
coming up Nick just took it up a notch
on Wednesday while hyping up his
wife-to-be on Instagram
after Priyanka shared this snap cozying
up to her man captioned bei the singer
took to the comments with the best
comment ever writing red dress
[Applause]
[Music]
naturally every loyal Jonas Brother fan
freaked out over Nick's iconic reference
and we just hope he sang it when he
typed his comment soon Priyanka will
probably be ditching her red dress for a
white wedding gown to say I do too Nick
yes I'm very excited about it too it a
source told et quote Priyanka has
already been planning the wedding for a
couple of months now and is excited to
call Nick her husband one day I totally
want to get married at some point as for
what she has in mind for her big day
Priyanka opened up to et at the 2018
Golden Heart awards about the wedding
style she envisions when walking down
the aisle everything that I wear I have
to be comfortable and cute so it's gonna
be cute and comfortable our source adds
Nick and Priyanka want to get married
earlier rather than later and the
lovebirds are telling friends they will
most likely tie the knot in 2019 and
Nick is setting the foundation for his
future with the quantico actress another
source tells et Nick bought a six point
six million dollar mansion around the
time he started dating Priyanka